entertainment tonight is back in
production here on our studio lot
and as you can see right behind us covid
19 testing for everybody who enters now
these precautions are important because
anyone can catch kovid just ask
the new batman robert pattinson or
dwayne johnson
my wife lauren as well as my two baby
girls
and myself we have all tested positive
for covid19
this has been one of the most
challenging and difficult things we have
ever had to endure
as a family the rock spoke candidly in
the 11 and a half minute video calling
the positive covet test
a kick in the gut for our babies jazzy
and tia
they had a little sore throat first
couple of days
lauren and i we had a rough go but we
got through it
so what happened here's how we got cobit
19. we
picked up covet 19 from very close
family friends
how common is this that people can track
this illness while visiting friends and
family
it is so common kevin listen so many
people
are asymptomatic carriers of covid and
they don't realize that they look good
they feel good
and so they're going around friends and
loved ones and they're transmitting it
and making others sick this is very very
common this is why we have such a big
problem
the 48 year old former wrestler says
he'll now require
loved ones to get a covet test before
visiting i love that advice or
have people outside we have people come
to my house they stay outside in the
backyard
about 15 feet away we talk and that's it
no one comes into my house unless it's
an emergency
one factor in the rock's favor
his discipline and commitment to fitness
here's the thing kevin
i'm a bad when it comes to working out
i left the gym i left everybody in it
people who tend to be healthier
going into the illness tend to come out
on the other side
better and there's another twist today
there are multiple reports that robert
pattinson has tested positive for the
coronavirus
causing filming of batman outside london
to be halted
three days after shooting began i'm
vengeance
pattinson's rep in warner brothers
wouldn't comment on any individual's
health
but today the studio tells e.t quote a
member of
the batman production has tested
positive for covet 19
and is isolating in accordance with
established protocols